how far are you on squid game uh all the
way but that last episode hasn't come
out yet I know it's kind of a [__] move
by them we're saving the last one you
know come on I love how the instant
turns the guy got the advantage yes yeah
it's so good the player have to
eliminate he's like what the fu yeah
yeah yeah like so [__] they rules
yeah they rules it's just like I like
how that every like my favorite thing
about this thing is how everyone talks
about fairness it would be fair if we
did nothing about this show is fair it's
the lottery that's all it is it's just
you have a little bit better odds yeah a
lot better odds if you get on the show
but like still it's just completely
random what you should do is you should
be a big enough personality to catapult
yourself to become a like a game show
Regular like across multiple networks
exactly you know exactly that seems to
be like an actual viable like launch
platform now for people's like like
celebrity and
their their influencer career or
whatever is just be a person that people
resonate with yep and then you'll just
get cast as like a Bravo or [__]
Netflix Regular bro I so watch Love
Island games or whatever everyone does
it now I'm watching the new season of
The Challenge and it's funny I they have
such a unique like good problem as far
as media goes cuz the orig
40 Seasons or whatever were successful
and it was just pretty much the same
rotating cast and all these people would
train and it was like you knew that they
were going to try and so they're trying
to start that over mhm they actually had
the show running in tandem on MTV and
another Network okay with just different
cast which is it's great I don't know
how many shows do that but that's pretty
crazy genius so yeah now this new one
it's all young people and they're only
like one or two seasons in mhm I was
just thinking dude if you're if you
failed out of some like a sport you you
couldn't make it to the NFL or something
go do this yeah you'll dust everybody
yeah do that and learn how to do a
[__] puzzle yeah and you can have a
career where you're making like I don't
know quarter Mill yeah half a mill every
couple every other year that's like your
big check and then you're just an
influencer the other the other days
yeah totally agree yeah so but yeah the
you and the thing is you you could just
be like the worst [__] person too and
it like almost works better yeah cuz
that [__] Tom sandal guy he's the one
on uh Vander pump rules that like had
the whole cheating scandal you didn't
hear about that at all no really no at
all not a single thing no wow we are
just in different different worlds dude
I kind of I kind of got like sucked into
the whole bra
world because Kelsey watched this show
so then I did like the typical husband
[__] where you're like standing in the
room you're like what the [__] is this
[__] and you you just kind of stand
there like why do you watch this [__]
waste of
time so let me just get
this oh he he cheated on her and they've
been dating how long and she froze her
eggs cuz they they're going to have kids
oh [__] that's [__] up and then I kind
of like sit down grab a snack this
[__] such a trash TV I can't believe
he would do that what a [__] [__]
yeah and they just turn turns it off
what are you
doing anyways this was a huge huge thing
why does this guy look like an AI Latino
yeah so he basically just he just cheats
on this girl like one of the fan
favorites of the show they find out that
she he's been cheating on her for like
the longest time with this horri other
girl on the show that's horrible right
and everyone's like this guy is just
like a complete narcissist just [__] bag
yeah this was like literally like five
six months ago this happened and and now
he's like a series regular on [__]
this new reality show where they like do
army [__] okay have you seen that one no
he's like on the [__] billboard for
it he's like the main
guy so good yeah that they just make
game shows and TV shows out of
everything there's that game show where
it's all blue collar people okay look
can you look at the name of that show
what they do this blue collar uh game
show world's toughest test I think it's
called tough special that's him on the
[__] thing
wow I think the show is called tough as
Nails sorry we're let's talking about
two different things at the same
time they got black chy on this yeah
dude Dez Bryant see what channel is
this this Show's [__] stupid it's on
Hulu I'm GNA watch it tonight yeah it
does look kind of sick
nah man I'm I'm biased to the but like
when this [__] happened it's like
everyone's like oh this guy's career is
over it's over it's never been bettery
yeah being a heel for a reality show
yeah oh look at him do they even make
him do his hair like oh they got boxing
each other
oh oh my God I guess that's probably
part of the appeal is that people like
want to see him do like go for hell
that's why you know like spite watching
it that's why Jake Paul made all that
money off boxing yeah true you know
everyone to see him get murdered and it
didn't happen Nick vile yeah I'm
laughing but I know that because I watch
The Bachelorette or the bachelor with
alinaa so you know who Nick V is of that
yeah so you're kind of in the Bravo no
no I am I'm definitely I'm I'm aware
yeah yeah I'm clued in to Bravo oh wait
is Bachelor Bravo no it's not ABC ABC I
didn't know that no but it's kind of the
same wheelhouse definitely yeah this is
hilarious I watched bachor in Paradise
for a little bit yeah yeah yeah yeah you
were saying it was pretty good sorry I'm
just chuckling at they knew they're like
we're going to put Tom sandville in the
in the boxing oh that's JoJo siwa oh
yeah I guess there's this one scene
that's going viral on Twitter or
something of it might be
Tom who like can't make it anymore and
JoJo just [__] picks him up and
throws him over her shoulder and like LS
them out of there wow yeah dude damn I'm
yeah I kind of want to watch it how do
how do we just convince ourselves to
watch I have to watch this dude cuz
they're good yeah I don't know cuz I
think on regular here's the thing with
love Island you get [__] bored yeah
just waiting for them to flirt and it's
stupid that's why games was good yeah
yeah yeah yeah it was the perfect
version of Love Island and way shorter
too when they but when they do [__] and
then when it's for money like this and
then it when they have teamwork oriented
stuff that's when the drama really fires
up yeah that's when they get look at
this guy massive he has
175 300 M tall yeah melb that was melb
did he realize go go to toughest Nails
how long has this show been running it's
it's like who is The Bluest of colors
it's tough his nails and it's just
showing these Blue Collar people cut
rebar cut like a 100 pieces of rebar or
you know that's
sick I think it's just funny
to yeah
there are so many people that do this
[__] every day they're like I could be
on a game show
yeah look how she cut look how she cuts
this wood look at them make a train
track this is I mean this is kind of a
good idea for a show watch this just
these people because they they've been
some of these people have been doing
this [__] every day for like [__] 20
years they're amazing at it yeah yeah
watch this just be like an extension of
the prison industry yeah these are all
like currently serving
yeah oh that that would actually add a
layer to the ship man I just gave him
the worst idea ever what what if we took
current inmates they do that don't they
yeah they they yeah that's what I'm
saying that they do hire inmates to do
construction but now I'm saying no I
meant like reality shows on Prison I'm
just merging the two and that would be
the ultimate [__] guilt watch
yeah